لا يمكن تعويله على سلاح واحد لخوض الحروب
والانتصار فيها لذلك نجد الحديث دائما عن
الحاجه الى انواع جديده من الاسلحه حسب
نوع المعارك المراد خوضها مؤخرا سمعنا
كثيرا عن طلب اوكرانيا لدببات ليوبارد
اثنين الالمانيه هذه الدبابات متطوره
وتطابق معايير النيتو لكن ليس هدف حزب هو
السبب هناك سبب
دبابات التي تعاني اوكرانيا نقصا فيها
قديفه دبابات ليوبارد من عيار 180 مليمترا
هذه القذائف تصنع في دول النيتو على نطاق
واسع ويمكن تزويد اوكرانيا بها لكن هناك
مشكله
الاصول الرئيسي لدبابات اوكرانيا هو من
طراز تي 72
السوفياتيه
والمتهالكه الان هذه دبابات لا تستخدم
قذائف من عيار 120 وانما قد افا من عيار
100 وخمسه وعشرين ولا يوجد مناطق تصنيع
كافيه له
واذا كان بامكان النيترو تزويد اوكرانيا
بالقذائف فليس لديها الدبابات التي يمكنها
استخدام هذه القذائف
كثر الحديث ايضا عن زياده في منظومه
هايمرس التي يبلغ مدى صواريخها نحو 90 كم
هذه المنظومه لديها صواريخ موجهه واستخدمت
بشكل رئيسيا لاستهداف خطوط امداد الروسيه
ومراكز القياده في الجبهات
واشارت تقارير الى انها اثرت في مجريات
المعارك بشكل كبير كما يجري الحديث عن دعم
اوكرانيا بناقلات جنود
سترايكر وتحاول دول النيتو بهذا المسيج من
الاسلحه تعزيز القدرات الاخرانيات على
اختراق الدفاعات الروسيه في الجبهات عبر
تعزيز القوه الناريه وقدرات المناوره